simone veil la première personnalité à
être élu à la présidence du parlement
européen
c'était le 17 juillet 1979
je voudrais vous remercier tous pour la
grande preuve de confiance que vous
allez donner en nommant à ce poste
éminent quelques mois plus tôt alors
ministre de la santé elle est choisie
par le président giscard d'estaing pour
mener la liste udf aux toutes premières
élections européennes
ma campagne ça ira d'être une campagne
d'explication et d'information
simone veil personnalité politique
préférée des français rescapés des camps
à auschwitz engagés pour la communauté
européenne
elle incarne la paix qui est le
fondement même de la construction
communautaire en 1951 l'europe avant
tout c'est la fin des conflits entre la
france et l'allemagne s'est déjà acquis
depuis maintenant un peu plus de 20 ans
je crois qu'il faut poursuivre dans
cette voie et poursuivre dans une phase
de perspectives de confiance une
perspective aussi de construction semble
d'autre chose tourner vers les autres
mais la campagne de simone veil n'est
pas de tout repos sa liste est ciblé par
les socialistes pour son manque de
femmes le rpr de jacques chirac lui fait
concurrence à droite
quant au front national il joue les
trouble fêtes en plein meeting
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand porte plus des aides arrivent en
tête le 10 juin 1979
27% des voix 25 sièges à strasbourg
simone veil brigue la présidence du
parlement elle est élue au second tour
je félicite madame veuve de son élection
l'adresse les meilleurs voeux pour
l'exercice de son mandat et je l'invite
à prendre place au fauteuil présidentiel
la première présidente enchaîne les
voyages à l'étranger reçu comme une chef
d'état elle dirige les débats
parlementaires parfois houleux c'est un
parlement qui comprend des représentants
des neuf pays avec des traditions
parlementaires différent donc des
habitudes quant à l'organisation des
travaux quant à la tenue de séances
je dirais que c'est une tâche à la fois
passionnante et difficile en 1981
simone veil reçoit le prix charlemagne
qui récompense une personnalité pour son
engagement européen
la première présidente du parlement est
aussi la première femme à l'avoir reçu
[Musique]